funny is that um
like you see a lot of men who are like
if you're like xyz like a lot of dating
profiles are like if you're like not xyz
like don't even bother like if you're
not if you're not we've got
we've got to be skinny we've got
that's in our control i like do not even
feel bad bad for women that get rejected
because of their weight like okay i've
been overweight like i'm
like statistically
and it was my own damn fault and you can
lose it like to be fair like uh
i can say i can say this from like a
thin privileged point of view that i'm
like something privileged you've earned
it one there well i haven't earned it
though i haven't earned it at all you
did from a calorie perspective you ate
less than other people yeah but that's
because of adhd that's like i just don't
eat it
but then but then it's like there are
some men who love a chunky woman or
someone who are like do you know what it
doesn't matter to me exceptions
exceptions that's it exception is not
the rule yeah exactly and everyone every
guy you see that's rich and and can has
has this pick of women yeah yeah who do
they like i'm gonna be real and most
women if you ask them would choose to be
thin like we're gonna be real about that
um but it still doesn't mean that men
like that's it and you see all these
like male podcasts at the moment who are
like if my wife gets pregnant and
doesn't lose the weight i might be
[ __ ] kidding me that's your wife and
she's gonna have your kid i think
i agree that like i agree with the men
yeah i think i i agree look at i'm sorry
i'm sorry look at it
i think of a girl okay if she gains 10
20 pounds but if you're getting like 50
75 pounds after you get pre or before
some girls do it before
yeah yeah he has a right to leave you
like but then does the woman have the
same rights yes okay good cool
yes women women
women leave all the time because of
financial reasons though
finance not fairness
i know but the difference is those are
both of things that you have within your
control does that make sense
i mean
finance is a bit more difficult because
obviously it depends on what job you get
well yeah so arguably if a woman leaves
a man for financial that's probably
harsher than a man leaving her for
weight because it's harder to get good
finances than it is to lose weight
yeah that's uh yeah i i can't disagree
with that sorry my my ex used to ask me
all the time not saying that depends if
she's a mother my children i think i
would i wouldn't leave because i think
that's because you know it's about the
kids but i think my expert asked me all
the time you know she was a dancer in
you know very good shape she's like oh
if i got like really really like obese
would you still love me i was like i
still love you but we just be friends
if i stayed in the same shape
if i kept the high standards like
because obviously if a girl is attracted
to me not because if part of her
attraction to me is because of my
physical
appearance or prowess or whatever
and then if i lose that i can't then get
pissed off if she loses attraction to me
if that was one of the major key factors
does that make sense or do you think
that's really bad
um
it's yeah it's
situational it's really yeah i
i can't ever argue that's the situation
that's his situation yeah that's your
situation so do you think in that
situation
he's wrong um
i would never like to tell someone
they're wrong i would never like them
but we're asking your opinion so you
know you if you think it's wrong the
floor is yours go ahead um
well then i think it comes down to
compatibility so if you're a person
that's like well i'm gonna really care
about my physique in xyz and they're
like well i'm not then it's like you're
very much not compatible and then i
don't think she's saying she has to have
abs everything oh no
i'm not saying he's just saying don't be
obese yeah yeah but then it's like if
you care
a lot about someone's physicality and
they don't care a lot about their
physical you don't think everyone cares
about physicality a blind person doesn't
a blind person does not why do you look
for the exception to every rule because
you know when you know this well you
know what i'm talking about in general
no but kindness and obviously like then
there are people who can't help being
paralyzed or like and so that's like i
had a boyfriend who once was like um
let's be real if i was in a car accident
and you had to care for me the rest of
my life i couldn't sleep with you as
paraplegic i was like yeah of course i'd
stay with you but i know that there's
people who like genuinely would be like
oh i don't know if i could do that i
actually don't know if if you weren't
hot if i had to care for you if i
couldn't sleep with you there are people
who would be like and it doesn't make
them laugh did you know did you know
that women leave men 80 of the time and
if they're college educated it's 90. so
if you get divorced it's 80 of the time
like the woman leaves and one of the
number one predictors of a divorce is
actually if the woman out earns the man
oh i love that i actually love that i
can't lie actually you love that you
don't think that's kind of shitty no i'm
like girl you you go get that you go get
a man like yeah you go get that like
really yeah like why is there like a
lack of empathy for ben it's not lack of
empathy but there is because like
they're breaking up a family a lifelong
commitment in a home and your your
reaction is you go like go get that go
get the bag sister like i'm so happy for
you when that's actually a really like
that's a sad situation like your wife is
leaving you but then we could argue that
if a mom wanted it enough and wanted to
be enough then we could argue that but
he could be enough but he he can't
because he's she out earned him like
that's that's what i'm saying so in this
case if it was possible for her why
isn't it possible him for him
if she could do it and make that money
why couldn't he i think there are times
where you make less money like yeah my
dad's in the top half a percent of
earners there there were times where he
was barely making any money yeah and my
mom stayed because she's a loyal [ __ ]
and so i'm not going to say you go cis
when you leave a lifelong commitment and
a family you made because you're you out
earned your husband but then it depends
on if your priority is money if your
priority is right so what i'm saying
what i'm saying is that's selfish and
that's wrong
and like yeah and you're saying eugosis
and i say i have a lot of empathy for
the men that go through that yeah and so
i just don't understand this like like
why do we immediately take the woman's
side
oh not immediately no and
but right there you did because i gave
you some stats and some numbers and you
like that was and it's okay i think it's
normal actually i think it's like part
of a gynocentric social order yeah
because like we always like our our as a
society we always take the woman's side
like well i don't know why that is yeah
i think i think well from my own bias
that's it i would i'm not necessarily i
would actually this is the irony is i
would actually like a partner that out
earns me i would actually like a man i
would like i'm gonna fully be like i
would like a man almost most girls do i
would like a man i would like a man to
out earn me and take care of me however
i love the idea of being financially
independent and being successful and
this is where it's really like uh
because you know it doesn't work if i
was with a man that was like
i feel bad that you out earned me
i probably wouldn't respect him i can't
really explain why but then i'm also
like i i want to be able to be like i
want i'd like a man that's like
i respect the fact that at some point
you may out earn me and i'll be
comfortable with it but then i'm like
i would like a man to out earn me and
that is yeah yeah but that's that's the
thing like actions have consequences
right and so i think feminism often
tells women we can have everything we
can make a lot of money and have you you
you can make a lot of money you can have
the family and you can have a husband
that out earns you and actually you know
what like my mom actually did have
everything but everything comes with a
cost and people don't understand what
the cost is i think it's the bare
minimum like where women can
there's a bare minimum where you can
actually get everything you want and it
works out but i think but it's the
exception it's not the yeah 100
um just play devil's advocate because
that's my favorite things to do if you
haven't noticed um
so
you just said that you would like a man
who earns more than you and who can take
care of you which
most women
prefer as well
do you not think that's very
anti-feminist of you
no 100 100 and i know that comes from
um it comes from quote unquote daddy
issues it comes from growing from
poverty and it comes from also being you
know i think it's just natural part of
being a woman
i i can always pick my own experience
yeah yeah so for you do you not think
that desire to have a man who can take
care of you it's just part of being a
woman for you
no because i'm not straight
so
yeah do you do you i have a question are
you are you bi i'm pansexual
what is it i don't know what that means
um so pansexual means that you are open
to the possibility of being attracted to
anyone regardless of sex gender you you
did just say you wanted a man though
yeah yeah okay okay if it was a man
that's it if it was a woman if it was
someone who was transgender it might be
different okay question why because
because i have a couple of friends who
are bi who date men and women and they
apply a different standard for men than
they do for men why is that
um
because if it's about the person it's
not about the gender it's about the
person
why would you why do you why do you
apply different standards for a man and
i would argue maybe because i'm a man
but i argue the standards you have for
men are a lot higher than the standards
you would have for a woman why why do
you have why do you apply different
standards depending on the gender when
arguably if you date both it's actually
about the person
um yeah like that's a really good point
i think because arguably it's just
easier to be a man and so therefore
you're like well it's easier
why is it easier to be a man i mean the
gender pay gap just says it all out okay
but there's also a gap in like men
commit suicide more yeah men are
dropping out of colleges that's toxic
masculinity that men can't speak about
so then so then why are we saying that
there's like a patriarchy when men have
it hard too like why are you just saying
you said you just said women have it
harder than men but if women had it
harder than men like then why are you i
didn't say they had it harder i just
thought it was easy to be a guy then but
okay if it's easier to be a guy then why
do more men commit suicide because they
they feel because of toxic masculinity
which are perpetuated by both men and
women they feel like they have to be
macho and i don't subscribe to that at
all i'm very much like um well it could
be possible that men have a harder life
than women
yeah of course it could be possible of
course it could be okay so that would
like contradict what you said earlier
well this is it it's not black and white
it's not right or wrong yeah gray area
maybe yeah so everything is there's no
like very solid so yeah that's and
even the whole um
rule and exception there's all it's not
one-size-fits-all it's really not where
there is that there are some men who
thrive and succeed because they're a man
because life is easy therefore i'd be
like i would expect you okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna give you an example my dad's
the half top half a percentage of
earners okay he he's the white man right
that but but here's the thing he worked
80 hours a week my whole life i didn't i
didn't get to see him yeah how was that
like the patriarchy when my dad put in
80 hours every week his whole life
from the time i was like a child right
missed a lot a lot of a lot of [ __ ] like
he earned that yeah and i'm never going
to say that's like no the patriarchy
well the only way
now he's a white male ceo yeah right so
is is that the patriarchy or did women
not choose to do that well that's the
only way we could argue is the only
definitive answer you could have is if
you had a exact female replica to be
like she likely would not get where he
is
that's the only way we could argue it
right so it doesn't want to take away
from his efforts it doesn't take away
from so then why do we why do we talk
about it at all if you can't if you have
no idea why there's a pay gap
yeah yeah yeah like like it's is it
possible that it's the the industries
that women pick because if you if you
have countries that have more choice so
if you go to like the most egalitarian
countries there's more of a pay gap
rather than less because women choose
jobs with people
yeah jobs with objects so like my i'm
from a family of ten
all the boys are engineers none of the
girls are engineers like is it possible
it's a biological difference rather than
a patriarchy yeah no i think i think
well i think the pay gap is more like
within so i don't know if you saw on
international women's day they had a bot
that literally showed you the pay gap
within organizations so obviously women
will tend to go for things like being a
nurse being a teacher yeah they pay a
lot less than being
a financer
yes but the pay gap then exists in so a
lot of things where there's a lot of
male actors who will be like i will not
uh sign on to this contract unless i
know my female counterparts are being
paid the same and so i think the pay gap
then comes and well it's also the truth
it's also the trait like
disagreeableness so as women like we're
naturally more agreeable 100 so so we're
i'm more i'm terrible at negotiating i
just want to make everyone happy and i
just want to be like yeah i'll do
whatever for nothing and
um and but that's like men are more
disagreeable if you look at the
agreeability scale does that make sense
yeah yeah so again like why do we just
assume patriarchy when you don't know if
it's because of different personality
traits and gender differences no and
gender they are so real so in my studies
um it showed that so
men are more likely to go for so let's
say there's a job and a woman is more
likely to look at a job specification
and go
oh but she's more likely to say no to
herself and she's more likely to go
um
or i don't know if i'm good enough yeah
whereas a man is more likely to actually
inflate their ability and be like i'm
gonna go for that and it actually
reflects in relationships where a man is
more likely to actually shoot above and
be like yeah yeah i can i can yes
so it's a reason we see a lot of um
less attractive men with more attractive
women the women are more likely to be
like look i spent a lot of my life being
like i'm a 4 out of 10. i'm
i'm probably about seven but i spent a
lot of my life dating men and people
would be like amy that guy is not in
your league like why do you not and
they're like they're definitely like you
know
out like you're out of their league and
it's actually yeah there's a real gender
difference and
is that biological is it social
well
right there that's because men and women
men and women value different things
men value looks more women don't value
looks as much they value things like
social status like a blue check mark
a blue and this is i've dated a guy with
a blue check mark right like we'd like
social status yeah like we'd be lying if
we said we didn't care no no or or
whatever it is like it's it could be
height right it could be like it could
be you know maybe he's not as good
looking facially but he's he makes money
yeah or he makes money yeah right and so
that's why we see there's a gap in that
yeah but we don't we don't scream
patriarchy for like men
yeah like but then we don't know that's
it we don't know is it because of
uh so you've got the biopsychosocial
approach um and that which is what i
tend to um subscribe to because that's
it it's not easy to be like oh it's just
biology or it's just sociology or it's
just your personal my question is like
yeah i just don't even understand like
in this day and age how we are fighting
the patriarchy like what more can they
do i can do any job i want
like nothing has ever stopped me from
doing anything yeah so like i don't even
know like i don't even know what i need
feminism for now like i can't think of
one thing um i have a
question going back to what you said and
i think it's bad but i want to
give you a scenario so you said
originally that the reason you arguably
apply a higher standard to men is
because you felt life was easier for
them so it's easy
you should expect more from them
or they have advantages
right more so than women right